valencia hat jetzt klar gesagt woran das
leben tausender menschen hängt
das leben von tausenden von menschen
hängt direkt von der geschwindigkeit
unserer partner ab von der
geschwindigkeit mit der sie ihre
entscheidungen durchsetzen der ukraine
zu helfen die geschwindigkeit der
partner und dann kommt diese nachricht
die ersten schweren waffen aus
deutschland sind jetzt da
panzerhaubitzen 2000 dafür gibt es dank
hier auf twitter vom ukrainischen
verteidigungsminister alex s nikkor van
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht die sich heute mittag übrigens
im bundestag erklären muss unterdessen
droht putin dem westen weiter wieder mit
atomraketen wieder mit irrsinnigem nazi
vergleichen jetzt vor absolventen der
militärakademie in moskau er spricht
darüber wie er seine armee aufrüsten
will
[Musik]
er schwere waffen seit monaten erfordert
die ukraine die von deutschland seit
wochen in deutschland sie versprochen
und jetzt sind die ersten tatsächlich da
und darüber werden wir sprechen
zugeschaltet aus dem umkämpften don was
ist und selbstbild vize paul ronzheimer
guten morgen paul endlich sind ein paar
waffen da doch im vergleich mit anderen
partnern mit anderen ländern wie steht
deutschland da da
die menschen hier haben die sorge dass
es zu spät kommt dass die waffen zu spät
kommen das ist nicht genügend munition
gibt dass all das was man jetzt liefert
also die panzerhaubitze davon sieben
stück nicht ausreicht um 1500 meter
frontlinie 1500 kilometer frontlinie zu
verteidigen patriziern hier wo ich bin
in kramer tors dass die sorge groß dass
eben bis ende dieser woche lohans die
gesamte region erobert sein könnte von
den russen dort ist der kampf heftig wir
sind auf dem weg auch genau nachliest an
scalzo diese stadt um die es geht dort
gibt es seit monaten bereits kein wasser
mehr keine elektrizität kein handynetz
funktioniert nichts mehr patricia und
man glaubt dass die russen diesen ort
jetzt demnächst einnehmen können
das ist eine ganz gefährliche reise die
du jetzt heute an diesem tag vor der hsv
schilder uns mehr darüber wie es in
dieser region aussieht wie es den
menschen dort geht und was es auch für
die ukraine bedeutet wenn dort weiterhin
diese einkesselung voranschreitet
tja die reise dorthin du hast es
angesprochen ist schwierig ist
kompliziert und ist wahnsinnig
gefährlich denn es gibt nur noch wenige
straßen die dorthin führen patrick sein
man muss sich das so vorstellen
die russen haben vor diesen bereich
komplett einzukesseln also komplett
einzuschließen und dann die ukrainische
armee dort stellen zu können zur aufgabe
zu zwingen oder dort alle zu töten und
die menschen die dort leben die
sind
völlig verzweifelt die meisten von ihnen
sie sagen wir können da nicht raus wir
wissen nicht wohin wir wissen nicht
genau in welchen regionen wir gehen soll
wir haben nicht genug geld all das ist
das was dort eine rolle spielen jeden
tag versuchen freiwillige auch
internationale wir von europäern hier
hast du wieder oder hört man wieder
einen einschlag selbst sind kantors das
eigentlich etwas entfernt das aber als
nächstes ziel sein könnte und genau das
ist genau diese sorge patricia
nachlässig tanzt das kommt als nächstes
dann könnte dieser ort hier dran sein
drama tors dann könnte das la vie ans
dran sein und dann könnte das auf
größere städte aktiv toni kroos' sabrina
gehen also ein endloser krieg dass sich
die situation der gerade und auch
präsident zelaya hat gesagt das leben
der menschen dort das hängt jetzt ganz
konkret von der hilfe ab jetzt haben wir
endlich offengelegt was wir geliefert
haben und was wir liefern werden was
braucht aber die ukraine was fordert
auch der präsident ganz klar denn die
zeit die spielt ja gegen die ukrainische
armee
absolut die zeit spielt gegen die
ukraine momentan die russen sind im plan
vorteil man sah es dass es hier zum
einen um munition geht das stellt ein
großes problem dar weil die sowjetischen
oder früher sowjetischen depots
aufgebraucht sind und es geht um schwere
waffen patricia also
panzerabwehrwaffen zum beispiel die man
gut in kiew gebrauchen konnte die sind
momentan zumindest in diesem krieg im
krieg der artillerie nicht wirklich
nützlich es geht um weitere
panzerhaubitzen um artillerie das ist
das entscheidende hier paul ronzheimer
und zugeschaltete aus dem don was paul
wir denken an dich bei dieser reise wir
werden jetzt erst mal in den nächsten
stunden keinen kontakt zu der haben
können und hoffen dann der arbeit von
dir zu hören damit uns die uns weitere
schilderungen erlebnisse aus diesem
krieg dann mit bringen kannst danke dir
und gleichzeitig die nachricht hier in
deutschland die geheimhaltung ist
endlich aufgehoben die bundesregierung
sagt endlich ganz genau welche waffen
sie in die ukraine geliefert hat welche
nicht das war ja bisher anders jetzt
aber jetzt ist die sache klar dennoch
fragt man sich warum drucks das holster
so lange rum und was bringen diese
waffen sie sehen hier die liste der
ukraine wirklich ja über diese liste und
das lange herum drücken sprechen wir
hier mit unserem bild militärexperten
julian ratei uns bei bild live größe die
schon guten morgen julian also warum
jetzt warum erst jetzt und warum dann
aber doch jetzt diese liste ja also die
liste hängt bereits seit april glaube
ich mit april im bundestag aus kann dort
einmal wöchentlich einer geheimen stelle
eingesehen werden von den jeweiligen
bundestagsabgeordneten heißt auch darf
man nicht fotografieren nicht rausnehmen
und so war das einmal reingucken und
buch wieder zuschlagen ganz genau man
darf rein guckt man darf kein handy
dabei haben man wird überwacht während
man guckt das problem ist nur dass diese
liste in den letzten wochen überhaupt
nicht mehr erneuert wurde überhaupt
nicht mehr aktualisiert wurde und
deshalb immer mehr
bundestagsabgeordnete auch bei uns
öffentlich damit gedroht haben zu sagen
wenn ihr uns weiter jede woche die
gleiche liste zeigt auf der nichts neues
drauf steht dann werden wir das mal
fotografieren dann werden wir diese
liste mal auch ein bild und eine andere
weitergeben deshalb jetzt die flucht
nach vorne der bundesregierung die sagen
so jetzt haben uns davon frei gemacht
sozusagen jeder kann die liste einsehen
keiner kann uns mehr sagen wir könnten
die vielleicht abfotografieren und
gleichzeitig nachricht panzerhaubitzen
2000 werden jetzt geliefert lasst uns
mal ein bisschen in die details gehen
und was das der ukraine bringt und was
diese zahlen was diese liste überhaupt
bedeutet für jeden der keine waffen
spezielles ist sagt der gut jetzt haben
wir das aber was macht das mit den
soldaten mit den menschen im krieg die
dort kämpfen was bringt das wirklich
also die wichtigsten dinge auf der liste
waren bisher bis gestern bis zu dieser
panzerhaubitze 2000 natürlich auf der
einen seite die flugabwehrraketen und
auf der andern seite die
panzerabwehrraketen also die singer ist
auf der einen seite und die panzerfaust
reihe aus bundeswehrbeständen die dort
geliefert wurde die wurden aber schon
ende februar geliefert das ist eben das
problem also wir haben am anfang gut
geliefert wir haben die ukraine im
ersten moment gut unterstützt haben aber
dann ja vier monate fast nichts mehr
hinterher geliefert
gestern endlich gott sei dank ist diese
panzerhaubitze 2000 dazugekommen werden
gestern darüber berichtet da gab es
höchste geheimhaltung die dinger sind
also ich weiß gar nicht wie ohne dass
jemand sie fotografiert hätte heim nicht
aus deutschland über polen in die
ukraine gekommen niemand was wirklich
habe ich noch nie erlebt niemand hat sie
auf dem weg dahin auf den zug
fotografiert sie sind jetzt da sie
sollen nach unseren informationen in den
nächsten tagen schon zum einsatz kommen
und sie wären extrem dringend benötigt
nach dem ganzen hin und her dem letzen
gewese um diese lieferung verspätet was
kommt drauf auf die liste was steht
überhaupt dort auf dieser geheimen liste
die so lange geheim gehalten wurde jetzt
also ein bisschen mehr transparenz hast
du aber dafür eine erklärung gefunden
warum dieses ganze hin und her
entstanden ist war das unwillen oder
fehlende fähigkeiten fehlende kompetenz
also wenn du mich fragst ich glaube es
hat was mit dem immer noch vorhandenen
pazifismus und dieser idealen ich möchte
sogar sagen ideologischen ausrichtung in
der spd zu tun man wollte irgendwie der
ukraine helfen aber irgendwie auch mit
putin in kontakt bleiben irgendwie immer
so ein bisschen dazwischen sein man
wollte nicht offen sagen guck mal wir
geben hier panzerhaubitzen dass er hat
man das alles sehr sehr sehr geheim
gehalten und nochmal mader will die
ukraine seit märz haben steht davon
nichts drauf wird auch steht auch nicht
für die zukunft drauf wir haben ein teil
der liste wird auf den in der zukunft
machen wir das auch diese gebhard panzer
die ja schon vor glaubt einem monat
angekündigt wurden da hieß es 5 kommen
sofort der rest im juni es ist noch
keiner da jetzt heißt es juli die kommen
alle irgendwann mal wir müssen mal sehen
ob diese liste auch wirklich hält was
sie verspricht oder das
wie wir es ja bisher schon kannten
ankündigung waren für die zukunft von
bis zu 2000 endlich da große ausnahme
ankündigung für die zukunft die bissig
sich bisher nicht gelöst haben und diese
liste kann jeder einsehen julian auf der
seite der bundesregierung und auf
bild.de ihr habt sie ausgewertet dann
kein bild mit experten julian rottke
danken dir